the fact is  the rates of violent crime are higher in  Oklahoma under your watch than in New  York and California that's a fact  well we'll have that fact checked by the  frontier superintendent it's also a fact  that medicines do you believe we have  higher crime than New York or California  that's why she just said  Safety and Security is my so Kevin's tit  says that doesn't sound right you you  people don't believe that right and the  cloud goes no no this is the way they  operate it just doesn't sound like the  very stuff we've been repeating so it  can't possibly be true right but it is  very much true these red state folks  have no idea that they are being lied to  and that blue cities and blue states are  being scapegoated for no reason that has  any connection to reality